cole irvin has been a great story of
course for the years this year he'll be
starting for bob melvin's ball club he's
three and three in a 309 era
here's yandy diaz
outfield room in left center a line
drive to center canada going back and
he's going to get there about 20 feet
from the track and he makes the catch
that ball was it right on the button so
the rays fail to score with the a's
coming up in the bottom half
and young shane mcclanahan will make his
third major league start for the raise
his first ever start in the big leagues
was against the athletics got to bear
down and get chapman
the man who
got a couple of hits and runs bettered
in against
mcclanahan and saint pete
murphy goes to 3-2 pitch breaking ball
popped up into shallow lift it's the
third baseman wendell fighting the sun
gives way to what thomas and willie
makes the catch wendell i think lost the
ball in the sunshine he looked to adonis
and willie said i've got you covered and
willie made the play preventing a run in
nbc
mike bronso leads it off for the raise
top of the second there's no score paul
is not afraid of contact
which i think is one of his strengths he
trusts that his pitches will do what he
wants most of the time
turns ready delivers in frosto swings
and misses on a fastball up and away
down he goes
first strikeout for irvin
mike cenino with two out nobody on
now the 2-2 and that's on the inside
corner fastball ring him up strike three
call
and for urban he works a one two three
second with two strikeouts
and after one and a half still no score
now steven piscotti
here's a half swing and a miss
and he struck out the scotty looked like
the slider down
and with two out
that'll leave him for mitch morgan one
ball two strikes mcclanahan throws
swinging a miss he struck him out a
hundred with a fastball moreland retired
back-to-back case for mcclanahan and
looks like he's settled in a bit through
two it's the raise and the a scoreless
andrew's sitting at buck 55 without a
home run there's a swing and a miss at a
ball down in the dirt and andrews is out
on strikes and that's three straight
strikeouts now
so with two outs here's jed lowry lowry
walked the one-two pitch as a check
swing he went around and it's a
sword-like swing
for lowry and he's out on strikes and
another one two three inning for shane
mcclanahan now sean murphy
now you don't even have a run yet today
in the pitch here swung out and missed
strike three got murphy to go chasing
and it's another strikeout for shane
mcclanahan two gone here in the fourth
and
trying to see there's nobody warming up
in the raised bullpen right now so
mclanahan who's had about 57 pitches
might be able to go a little deeper
today who knows so two on two out for
piscotti who struck out in the second
[Applause]
two pitch
is looped into right center field then
it's gonna fall for a base hit
chapman's gonna score the throw to third
and he is safe there's brown and the a's
lead one nothing
so on a no two pitch piscotti hung with
it dropped it in the right center field
so one nothing oakland bottom of the
fourth and here's moreland mitch struck
out on a 100 mile an hour fastball
back in the second
three balls and two strikes
mcclanahan's pitch slaughtered stroke
left side it gets by adamus and into
left center field it's going to score
two runs
brown is home biscotti is home moreland
delivers a two-run single the a's now
lead it three to nothing
here comes elvis
they're gonna have to play catch up
again today
[Applause]
[Music]
fly ball center field phillips ranging
back reaching up to make the grab
the a's do some damage though and they
do it all with two outs rosso with third
window at second three-nothing oakland
fifth inning aboard the race needs some
sort of an answer
and here comes willie adams the
left-hander's pitch to a dumbest line
drive down the right field line towards
the corner piscotty turns and looks it's
gone an opposite field three run homer
by willie adamus to tie the game it's
three to three
adonis with a little oppo action right
there
just tucked it in over the wall over
there in right field and for willie
homer number four rbis nine ten and
eleven and that had to feel
really really good austin meadows leads
it off for the raise top of the sixth
inning here's the 2-2 pitch swung out of
miss tied him up inside meadows strikes
out first strikeout for cole
two-out base is empty for mike brasso
now the signs from the catcher murphy
into the wind-up irvine the left-hander
to the play swinging a fly ball hitting
to left field fairly deep going back
brown to the track to the wall gone
and the rays take the lead
we've been saying how mike brasso needs
to do a little better against lefties
and he just took a pitch middle of the
plane and launched it over the
scoreboard and left and the rays lead
4-3 and here's joey wendell 1-1 pitch on
the way is a little one-hopper to shore
charging up with it elvis cross the body
throw for the out
but the rays take the lead on mike
rosso's home run we go to the bottom of
the six four three tampa bay
and the tying run for the a's is less
than 90 feet away
so here's marcanna
gotta be careful here with fairbanks
and those sliders
and the tying run less than 90 feet away
and the pitch on its way breaking ball
in the air to center but right there
is phillips and will make the catch
and that will retire the side
done with seven now there's two on with
two outs
and here comes that guy again seth brown
two on two out the 01 to brown bounced
in and it gets away
and as it does the throw goes to third
and they got him it was a late break
by olson zenino scampered to get it and
threw him out and the a's have just run
themselves out of this inning
so zanino hustled after the baseball
wendell got to the bag and olson was
late and coming off of second base
seeing that the ball got away and he
gets thrown out and that is a crucial
out number three
here in the eighth inning i thought that
they were going to take a look at it but
i guess they're not then the winning run
to the plate and up steps to elvis
andrews kemp running it first
and a 2-1 count on the shortstop elvis
andres
and the ground ball to third
wendell's throw to first razor winners
ray's win this one 4-3 andrus out
wendell to diaz
and the rays take the final game of the
series and the road trip and finish the
trip five and two
the rays defeat the oakland age
salvaging one of the games here in
oakland and ultimately the rays put
together a five and two west coast trip
all the way out there in california the
rays win